bullet cat podcast shout out lrg we got
a special guest in here very special he
flew in from mexico city so that mexico
the homie speaks that's me antonio hello
hey i love the ecw you know this is that
stash pages i gotta shout them out to
homies the homie chris from stash pages
you know i feel like paulie dangerous in
this [ __ ] i love it man feel like this
is the tommy dreamer kid i love shout
out to tommy dreamer the dream yeah man
listen we we're on some ecw uh energy
today we are this guy came in he's i'm
the best rapper alive i am and argue
with your [ __ ] mother about it in the
comments no you're not that's cap that's
cap you're a liar one hunna shut the
[ __ ] up i'm the best play that [ __ ]
let's just get to this [ __ ] man let's
talk about that come on man let's talk
about it hello hello this is me antonio
you might know me as speak the best in
the world yeah that's me oh you don't
like that i'm so sorry yeah
look [ __ ] your chain i want that 98
shania twain leopard print in the desert
smoking out to iron maiden born and
raised in like the sadie hawkins keep
your eyes above my pockets we've been
grinding since the auto rocket no squids
no poses no lames you repackaging that
mid trying to tell them that it's flame
well you not in a foreign you would
tweak us on a train getting dropped off
in pomona should have stayed up in your
lane when the police came around my
people weren't afraid got the lawyers on
retain a year around and they've been
paid rage for you roaches i'm praying in
the ocean that when i pass away there's
mariachis and some roses my hero's
growing up with selena and psychosis and
the doughboys in the max 97 where the
code is my neighborhood idols never saw
old age every gray in my beard is a
portrait of a place and the time i
survived your thea said i would survive
so i took an asteroid she had the time
of her life i told her load up dismount
ballin on the discount max holloway
bless fight you with the chin out 10
toes down i kept my feet in the soil
serve a 10 piece meal feeling like the
one boil tortillas with that side of
rice you know that boy is nice and if
the fools are tripping catch them with
your anaconda vice god damn animated
like kablam got a redhead [ __ ] that i'm
calling pepperon with another red head
that i'm calling peppa potts heard you
wanna talk a deal how much cheddar do
you guys stop guess
i'm getting goat cheese betty gold in my
nose when i sneeze allergy [ __ ] shoulda
took allegra coulda popped the benadryl
theo want a sick one and my sex appeal
like antonio vendettas strapped in
desperado my clique is 50 deep looking
like we saying
a ledge around the city give a [ __ ] if
you support us cause you boys pathetic
awesome dj academics some women hating
in cells i do not respect it i hate
rapists bigots homophobes and grown men
that gossip bottom feeding out the trash
eating with the possum josem moved
around the city with the street sharks
library at my house and i got the street
smarts you little vocals really dumb as
you look [ __ ] so proud that
they don't read books y'all are crusty
dusty whole or a musty i'm blowing up
the megalomark killing off you buckley's
iron shame what's on a song when i hit
the water bomb alone on my own level
every verse a monologue you want a
dialogue there's nothing much to talk
about except that super fake gangster
[ __ ] you not about i'm into peto by
myself you know they love me dog that
hunger in my belly holy like the ramadan
you not an artist you cosplaying like
it's kamikana call up art label kill em
dedicated shaka khan yeah best in the
world argue with your [ __ ] mother
about it we left the house for this
coming soon baby
the art of both shout out
your best the best what i was the best
in
i was the best in 2015 and i'm the best
now theo speak in the building you
already know how you feeling i'm feeling
that was amazing that was effortless
that's what i do that's what i do jesus
that's who i am
hey we gotta listen we got to try to get
you back on
ron our test is about to come in here
meta but we gotta do we gotta have a
friend of mine we gotta do an interview
with you i feel like we should shoot the
[ __ ] for a couple of hours
we got a lot to talk about how many ba
had me back in like
like two months two more minutes when
i'm a multi-millionaire there it is
shout out to speak ladies and gentlemen
hey i know you just watched the crazy
freestyle appreciate you watching make
sure you subscribe and make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [ __ ] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [ __ ] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off your
next order at lrg
all you got to do is use the keyword and
by keyword i mean promo code
use the promo code kev 30. that's kev
30. we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r dash g dot com all right we'll
put the website right there cook put the
website right there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev 30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[ __ ] contest just use the code and
you got it alright shout out to lrg